now we're talking
oh it disappeared we're good
jake we're gonna play this game the
worst possible way
meaning we're gonna play it on xbox one
bass but we're not gonna update it so
what you're looking at and what you'll
see is
version one and jake and i are gonna try
to play
this game through its entirety to see if
it is
even possible that's pretty much it so
this xbox is not connected to the
internet i bought it on disk i installed
it
and we are going to try to see how far
we can get by
playing through this incredibly buggier
version of a buggy game
more or less but anyway let's just start
let's just start uh i think okay yeah i
think easy's the right is the right way
to go
yeah i feel like that sort of difficulty
is not what we're looking for in this
play through
uh but the big question what life path
do we want to go with here
you have beaten the game and you're
you're the expert here so i
will use your discretion so i've done
nomad and street kid
uh any of them could work well for what
we're trying to do
uh maybe nomad could be interesting
because you start out in the open
area and we get a better look at like
the game's draw distances and whatnot
okay yeah and it's also worth saying
that uh not only are we playing it in
the worst possible way but we're going
to be playing a character
in the worst possible way so the idea
being that uh for those familiar with
dirty arty we're gonna play
as uh or try to roleplay as a basically
a piece of [ __ ]
uh and and be a scumbag uh to kind of
fit the tone
uh hair color uh how about something
very like split pea soup gross green
like snot like he's rubbing his hair
yeah it's almost like uh are we creating
the
inadvertently creating the joker yeah
that's pretty good all right something
visually is happening that's very weird
oh yeah god i'm just noticing that it's
that it's that pulsating flicker
it's returned it's come back
dude when has that ever worked for
anyone
that is just such a gross
it's about to work for v what's what's
i like i like your philosophy of just
picking the highest number what's what's
uh what's the highest number on the
biggest system maybe we'll maybe we'll
see it later
oh right well they gotta be
oh he's not he's not one to groom
himself i want to have a little fun
while we're playing as him you know i
want to see the checkers
it's just there's something more fun
about that you know sold
uh nipples off
body scars you can do that i mean i i
kind of think we should do
yep body just because i agree i feel
like he's a puncher
i would agree checks out
no nipples all right time to see how
long the loading is on this thing
oh
[Music]
this is gonna be a ride man
and here we go we should leave all of
this in oh yeah i think we should
oh my god is that the bar ticking
so slowly it is moving slow it
definitely makes me appreciate those
uh ssds that are in the next gen
consoles now
because oh boy makes all the difference
oh it's speeding up though here we go
there are some jumps
all right there we go it wasn't too bad
crash just crashes
okay so far i see black that's all there
is
[Music]
beautiful
oh and there's the jacket oh my god just
slowly stacking oh
this is gonna be quite the
up with experience wrist oh
then stop looking bye
bye okay all right
oh oh interesting
oh did that hurt
or well it wasn't that wasn't that big
of a jump
that hurt you yeah but i like glitched
in the air i couldn't do anything for a
little bit
what's this there's a there's like a
weird
like like reflection behind the car yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting
it's like it's like copy and pasting the
reflection like multiple times
that helicopter is uh it's kind of
suspended huh
it's kind of just chilling
[Music]
nothing scandal papers
did you hit what did you oh this thing
get in your car i got a real bad feeling
about this
me too gun please
give it here
all right what happened there
[Music]
my shoulder yeah
now we're talking
all right it is uh
definitely harder to shoot at this frame
rate
oh it disappeared we're good
[Music]
city oh dreams
there he is
oh god
[Laughter]
it's moving so fast i can't keep up
it's like it cuts to a new scene and
then it loads all the assets and then it
cuts to a new scene before i can process
what's happening
it's like it's like like someone
juggling but they're dropping everybody
the city of dreams
wow now try to take them down in one
slick move
apparently we're not wearing anything
where did when did you switch
a tire oh there it is there it is oh
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
look
we're in it now
[Music]
did you see his neck though it was like
snapped backwards
go home you've had a really long day
oh [ __ ]
third time
[Laughter]
there it is she was skiing yeah yeah
let's end it on this mirror okay
there it is there's our guy well
thank you jake thank you guys for
watching and stay tuned to next episode
uh i guess you know we could call that
most of the
intro tutorial i mean there's there's
still we haven't seen uh title screen
yet huh
no we have not it'll be a bit before we
do okay well we'll uh end it there and
uh
yeah thanks for watching and stay tuned
for more of
the worst way to play cyberpunk 2077